chris Christie of course everyone knows
what happened they shut down some lanes
in fort lee new jersey on the way to the
George Washington Bridge it now turns
out that it might have been political
retribution for a mayor of Fort Lee who
didn't endorse him when he was running
for governor he had the State of the
State Union yesterday in New Jersey
let's take a look at the last week has
certainly tested this administration
mistakes were clearly made and as a
result we let down the people we're
entrusted to serve I know our citizens
deserve better much better I'm the
governor and I'm ultimately responsible
for all that happens on my watch both
good and bad now without a doubt we will
cooperate with all appropriate inquiries
to ensure that this breach of trust does
not happen again but i also want to
assure the people of New Jersey today
that what has occurred does not define
us or our state okay I have no great
love for chris Christie but there is no
actual smoking gun here there were
emails that implicated other people he's
now fired someone and already is doing
the process that he's agreeing with the
with the legal system to go ahead and
deal with this uh so I have no great
love for the guy but there is nothing
pinning this on him specifically so I
don't know how much more the guy could
do at this moment if it turns out that
everything he said in the press
conference was not true then he'll have
to deal with that but the guy fired
somebody there's nothing pinning him
directly to it so how much more do
people want from him I again I'm
defending my yellow do the things I kind
of want to defend him to one because it
just doesn't seem like that big of a
deal like I realize that there are
consequences to it and like but there
are consequences to everything that are
unforeseen actually and people driving
like you never know what's going to
happen right supposedly there was an
ambulance and a guy area and like that's
obviously awful yeah but it's also like
the sort of badass to be like oh you
know I don't know I like weirdly find
myself being like that
kind of an awesome move like I hate to
be on that like I just remember like and
it's funny to me because like liberals
of course and i am count myself among
them ya think of for years the west wing
was like our refuge during the bush
administration like we could like for an
hour a week pretend jed bartlet
president one of the like funny moments
of his reelection campaign is that they
send of the presidential motorcade
through new york to keep the other guy
to tie up traffic so he keep the other
candidate can't get to an event and it
seems like oh man our liberal heroes are
so smart and funny and now chris
Christie does it and everybody's like
what a bully and it's like yeah that's
kind of why I like chris Christie little
bit goes a bad you know you totally hit
them where I wanted to go with this
thing because don't you feel like
everyone does this that doesn't diminish
what he did and especially if someone
died or that you shouldn't be doing
political retribution but are we to
believe do you not think the Clintons
have done this this you know if someone
doesn't endorse you then you go out and
try to harm them I'm not saying that's
how it should be revived as how it is
yeah but I mean you know it's part of
the problem and I do think like that the
traffic on a bridge is already terrible
and like all the points were raised
about like emergency service vehicles
not be able to get through yeah I mean
that's really bad I don't know like I
don't think there's any way to or any
reason necessarily sugarcoat it like
that is bad yeah but if they can't pin
it to him directly if there's no proof
and in the neck because they're gonna
keep pushing this obviously the media
likes this story and you can use all the
fat punzo everyone loves that well like
if they can't really pin it on him then
we sort of have to give a pass right he
fired the the woman that they could pin
it on like how much more can we ask them
to do yeah what else was he supposed to
do you know well that's my point that's
my point not defending him but the guy
did we always ask our leaders to take uh
you know acknowledge when something's
gone wrong he said is my fault even
though I didn't know about it I fired
somebody we we keep saying that Obama
you know then I say he doesn't know
exactly what was happening or Obamacare
you can keep it no was happening you
know it said I think that's exactly
right think there's a good argument you
made that he
didn't know I mean because especially
what's so frustrating i think part of
why the story is taking hold is because
nobody like liberals want to take down
chris Christie because he poses a threat
2016 yeah and Republicans don't love her
and so those are agree can we get out
from under chris Christie I mean like
good there's your fat baby but like kid
there they see it as opportune so
there's no but like glenn beck is
trashing chris Christie like there's
nobody usually this is the type of thing
where Fox News would close ranks and
talk about how the liberal media is
attacking a Republican leader who we
should you know that ridiculous they do
the same thing right but instead you've
glenn beck being like you know or rudy
giuliani you know who did defend chris
Christie actually came out and sort of
just like use the opportunity defend
obama to it was like he probably didn't
know what was going on with Benghazi or
what you know so you can't have it both
ways either you know Brock Obama doesn't
know everything that happens in the
country which I'm betting he doesn't
write or chris Christie you know he does
and chris Christie is totally an evil
mastermind you can't I totally agree I
mean how so how do who would want to go
into politics when you see a story like
this when you see this kind of thing
let's just say for a second he's being
honest and did not know nobody is in
charge of he's the guys at the head of
the state he's in charge of literally
thousands of people you don't know what
everybody's doing so who in their right
mind would ever want to run for public
office if everything that below you can
be pinned on you doesn't exceed nuts I
mean I especially the day when we
contract every right doesn't it seem
nuts yeah you want to run for office I
don't know yeah it sounds it sounds like
a job that I would not want yeah I mean
I I'm that's a question I mean who would
want for the closer reason it's anyone
down they'll say oh well your cheapest
after this twenty years ago and it well
that's it's that moment that is just
awful in like every movie we're like the
like every bad indie movie we're like
some like good people find themselves in
bad situations we're like the crazy
friend like brings a guy's head to like
look what I did for you
oh my God we're in trouble now I don't
want they it's like it's like there dog
bringing you a dead bird and you're like
no this is not a present like Scott like
and now he's responsible because it just
for a host of reasons one would not want
to run the fact that he's gotten this
far in fact anybody gets elected this is
a miracle to me yeah but I don't
understand the appeal of putting
yourself at risk for a thousand people
who all want to show that they're the
good soldier that's going to like do it
for right do it without even Tonya so
final thought on this related to 2016
and you touched on this isn't it's just
all too early if the goal here really
was to just hurt the guy you know they
could have sat on this because now
there's so these other little scandals
coming out so it's like you know when it
rains it pours kind of thing but isn't
all this too early there's no way we
can't remember anything a week later
much less this is way too early to do
damage the guy really don't you think
yeah yeah I think so um you know we've
got plenty of time you know plenty of
other scandals are going to happen
between now and then so um yeah i don't
know i mean it's it's crazy when you
think about even the last election if
you looked at it two months out before
hurricane sandy and stuff the election
was totally different yeah you know if
you looked at 2008 before the economy
tanked and mccain suspended his campaign
like if you looked at that I'm two
months before the election it was
totally different than what happened at
the end none of this matters it just
does just like Benghazi didn't destroy
Hillary this is not going to destroy
chris Christie like this is all just
gawking and something to fill our time
what we are agreed the eggs will destroy
Bieber right Oh for she has to have to
use all right Bieber
you